in breaking news ukraine's military says
russia has targeted port infrastructure
in the city of odessa with cruise
missiles they say two strikes hit the
black sea port and another two were shot
down by air defense
it comes a day after both countries
signed a deal brokered by turkey and the
united nations to reopen the ports to
resume grain exports the ukrainian
foreign ministry is now calling on both
the un and turkey to make sure russia
holds up its end of the deal
al jazeera correspondent to me
we saw missiles with the naked eye we're
talking about two missiles until now and
we've been able for the first time since
our arrival here to trace these missiles
they were really close just above us a
missile passed through here another pass
through there
the cameraman is able to show the
picture of the smoke from the
anti-aircraft rockets here on the black
sea shore until this moment we heard
four explosions in more than one
location here where we are standing one
minute before we went on air we can also
hear the siren alarms in the area they
went off right before the ukrainian
anti-aircraft missiles targeted what it
says are russian
rockets okay let's bring up a mat to
take a look a map rather to take a look
at this so up here you can see this is
odessa odessa port is one of the largest
ports in the black sea basin so it is
crucial for ukraine and of course the
black sea is where these grain exports
need to go through to ease the impending
global food crisis ukraine and russia as
we've said signed deals to allow the
exports of grain through the black sea
with turkey you can see down here
istanbul at the bottom which controls
the all-important bosphorous to inspect
ships to ease concerns of russia about
weapons smuggling well joining me now
from odessa is hannah schillest director
of security studies program at the
security think tank ukrainian prism
thank you very much for joining us so
you you heard these explosions or you
saw what happened tell us what you saw
yes definitely because i've been in my
summer house just on the beach so i saw
both the work of the air defense and of
the russian missiles as for now we
already have confirmed four missiles two
of which been
uh targeted by the ukrainian
counter-attack and two unfortunately uh
fall in odessa support and you need to
understand that all that support is just
in the downtown in the historical
downtown of the city so it's extremely
dangerous from all points of view and
you were absolutely right that it
happened less than 24 hours after
yesterday the grain deal was signed
where three ukrainian ports were named
and the odessa port is one of three two
others are just 40 kilometers
aside
and well russians targeted as far as we
know already exactly the grain terminal
so it's been as for me is real bullying
of the international community and
neglecting of that agreement that been
signed yesterday i mean there's 20
million tons of grain from last year's
harvest ready to to be shipped out um so
how do you think ukraine is is likely to
respond to this i mean
it's already said that this is putin
spitting in the face of the u.n in
turkey what do you think is going to
happen next
ukraine is trying uh since march to
export at least some amount of that
grains to the world market by land and
railway but capacities comparing to what
we could export by sea to what we can
export by uh land it is one to five so
as for now probably one million tons per
month that's what the road and the rail
um uh routes can help us because over to
romania paul and other neighboring
countries are trying to help so as for
now first of all we definitely need the
official explanations from the side of
the russian
side and what is even more important
that yesterday the agreement was tied by
the ministry of defense so they are
totally responsible for the yesterday
agreement and for today's uh missile
it's not ukraine is claiming it is
russian missiles it's definitely not
romanian the turkish missile against uh
oda support and uh we know
it's already confirmed by the official
side that it's been calibre missile the
russians used a very high precise
missile so they knew exactly what
they're targeting and why we haven't
heard from russia yet i'll get you to
stand by uh there for us ms cellist
because i want to take a look at what
that deal actually was or is so so a
joint turkish and u.n control center is
to be set up in istanbul it will control
all the deliveries of grain ukrainian
vessels are meant to guide the grain
shipments through mined waters in and
out of port
russia has promised not to attack the
cargo ships it did make that promise and
and turkey and the u.n will inspect
those ships however because russia is
worried that they'll be used to smuggle
weapons that's why they're going to be
inspected uh so the agreement will last
four months and will be renewed
automatically so hannah celeste do you
think that is the the end of that deal
then
uh as for now we hope that no uh because
we understand that it will be the punch
not only against the united nations but
also against turkey and turkey invested
a lot of effort to make this deal happen
and also i would like to clarify here a
little bit that joint center is not just
u.n turkish russian representatives also
will be there so russia received the
access for inspection they cannot claim
that they are not allowed to check what
is on the ship the only thing that these
inspections will be happening in turkey
in bosporus so their ships their
inspectors will not um be allowed at the
territorial waters of ukraine but still
that is quite a significant compromise
from ukrainian side as for now uh
everybody were talking that in 10 days
the first ship can go i don't know from
where this number of days appeared but
theoretically we definitely need to see
the establishment of the center the
appointment of the inspectors the
setting of the routes and procedures and
the question of the demining or at least
the minesweeper ships of the third
countries that is written in the
agreement that will accompany the ship
and it is not ukrainian ships it can be
the ship of any country under any flag
the only thing is that they are coming
to three ukrainian ports to export
ukrainian uh grains and ammonia because
the deal was a little bit wider it's uh
more about other types of the food and
ammonia because that is fertilizer
all right hey thank you very much for
your time there hannah celeste director
of security studies uh program at the
security think tank ukrainian prison
uh well ukrainian president vladimir
zelensky and russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov both hailed the grain deal
on friday saying it would mean positive
outcomes for both people uh in the
region and abroad
these are the incomes of farmers the
entire agricultural sector and the state
budget these are jobs these are funds
for next year's sowing there's a chance
here to reduce the seriousness of a food
crisis caused by russia and prevent a
global catastrophe a famine that could
lead to political chaos in many
countries particularly those that help
us
thanks to the efforts of the russian
delegation it was possible to maintain
the comprehensive de-politicized nature
of the agreement thereby ensuring the
maximum possible movement of grain
towards developing countries russia will
continue to be faithful to its
obligations in this area the use of food
by the united states and its allies for
their geopolitical interests is
unacceptable and inhumane